[Musique]
bonsoir anthony st léger on sort la
russie alors qu'elle affirme avoir
utilisé un missile hypersonique le 18
mars dernier deux vidéos circulent sur
les réseaux sociaux assurant attester de
cette frappe effectivement une frappe
qui aurait eu lieu selon les dires de
moscou contre un entrepôt souterrain
domicile et de munitions de l'armée
kényane dans l'ouest de l'ukraine
l'ukraine qui confirme avoir été touché
par un tir visant un entrepôt souterrain
mais sans plus de détails on précise que
si l'utilisation de missiles
hypersonique est avérée ce serait une
première en tout cas dans ce cas là on
va se concentrer d'abord sur une
première vidéo elle émane regarder du
ministère de la défense russe un compte
officiel via ce tweet qui date vous le
voyez du 19 mars et c'est important vous
allez voir pourquoi alors que voit-on on
voit un tir de missile
sur vu par un par un drone donc enfin
filmée par un drone pardon et qui a
détruit est des bâtiments que nous dit
précisément la publication destruction
de l'entrepôt d'armes des forces armées
ukrainiennes avec une frappe de missiles
d'autres précisions vous aurez noté
qu'il n'y a pas de ville mentionnez pas
non plus l'emploi du terme hypersonique
et la date de publication je le disais
19 mars est opportune puisqu'elle
intervient au lendemain de la frappe de
quoi entretenir la confusion dans un
contexte où on ne sait la guerre elle ne
se fait pas uniquement sur le front
stratégique on va dire mais de
l'information des deux côtés d'ailleurs
c'est important de préciser avec
évidemment la désinformation et la
cousine elle sa cousine la propagande à
leur plus bas dans ce même compte qu est
ce que vous trouvez vous trouvez cette
publication toujours fait le 19 mars et
qui renvoie cette fois vers un lien
facebook
celui ci que l'on voit ici il s'agit en
fait d'une déclaration du porte parole
du ministère de la défense russe et là
il annonce l'utilisation de ce missile
sur un dépôt de munitions baptisé ivano
frankivsk 16 près de la ville de délia
tine dans l'ouest de l'ukraine et que
c'est ton de cette vidéo de frappe et
bien si on regarde un petit peu plus
près c'est ce qu'ont fait d'ailleurs
plusieurs spécialistes de vérification à
d'image les lieux kition vie cible sur
la vidéo du ministère de la défense ne
correspond pas en fait à ceux du dépôt
de munitions de délia team qui est
mentionné par ce même ministre de la
défense ministère de la défense si on
s'arrête sur cette frappe regardez on
voit bien cette succession de bâtiments
aligner au moins siens moins cinq et on
voit aussi à droite tout un groupe de
bâtiments maintenant si vous regardez
une image satellite de la base divano
frank franklin x16 qui est évoqué dans
la publication facebook on voit que la
physionomie est différente bien sûr il
ya des bâtiments alignés on voit pas
cette rangée ou d'au moins 5 et ce
groupe de bâtiments sur la droite est en
effet ce média américain d' analyses
militaires et de défense nous explique
que la frappe en question elle a eu lieu
à 1200 km à l'est de là à tobolsk et ce
images satellites à l'appui regarder il
a comparé les images de topol ce que
donc à celle de la vidéo publiée par le
ministère de la défense et on voit les
mêmes bâtiments endommagés alors à
gauche vous avez celle de la vidéo on
peut noter aussi plusieurs petits
détails vous avez bien cette petite
allée que l'on retrouve par exemple ici
en tout cas ce chemin vous avez ici ce
qui semble être un bâtiment que vous
retrouvez ici il y aussi cette autre
bâtiment qui a la même forme et le même
placement que celui ci sur la droite
vous voyez qu'il ya plusieurs éléments
effectivement et pour cause pourquoi il
y à un rapprochement entre les deux
parce que il s'agirait en fait d'une
exploitation agricole qui a été frappée
le 12 mars dernier et lorsque vous
utilisez l'open source intelligence qui
va à la fois analysé les données
sanitaires satellitaire pardon elle
sanitaire c'est pour autre chose et les
zones aussi où les impacts de missiles
ont pu être observés et bien vous
obtenez cette photo satellite vous voyez
d'une exploitation agricole qui vous en
conviendrez quand même très très
ressemblante à la vidéo du ministère de
la défense un russe alors ce qu'on ne
sait pas en revanche c'est si cet
entrepôt agricole a été frappé ou non
par un missile hypersonique mais la
vidéo du ministère de la défense russe
ne montre pas un tir de missile
hypersonique ad dating comme s'est
affirmée dans les publications facebook
allez une deuxième vidéo a été relayée
là encore pour montrer les images du
missile hypersonique effectivement cette
vidéo elle est essentiellement partagé
par des proches de la droite américaine
ultra conservatrice qui affirme que donc
c'est ce missile hypersonique qui
travaillent traverserait le ciel
ukrainien alors pour cet exemple ça a
été beaucoup plus simple puisque comme
l'a repéré ce compte twitter on retrouve
la vidéo dans une boucle tik tok des
vous voyez regarder en haut c'est le 28
février donc ça n'à voir avec le
week-end dernier puis elle circule aussi
sur télégramme dès le 24 elle ne montre
donc pas ce tir de qinshan de tirmitine
kindle c'est ce qu'on sait son nom le 18
mars dernier et d'ailleurs je précise
qu'on n'a pas encore été pour l'heure en
mesure de l'identifier la localisation
de cette vidéo ni le connex et
d'ailleurs si vous avez des informations
à nous communiquer n'hésitez pas elle ça
se passe sur twitter c'est notre compte
at info ou intox f24
merci beaucoup anthony st léger vous
pouvez donc participé à l'élaboration de
l'actualité d'une actualité vérifier
avec nous sur france24 rester avec nous
on se retrouve dans quelques instants
pour un nouveau point complet sur
l'actualité internationale
[Musique]